Guten Tag. Dr. Erblen ist mein Name. Ich bin zuständiger Ersten heute für Sie.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnesi-Gespräch durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ich bin einverstanden, Herr Doktor.
Okay. Ich möchte zuerst ein paar Personen bezeugende Fragen stellen,
und ich möchte Sie über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden besprechen. Alles Nordnunk?
Ja, einfach schon.
Okay, wie heißen Sie bitte?
Mein Name ist Thomas Berthold.
Thomas mit TH, ja?
TH, richtig.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen büchtern?
Ja, Berthold schreibt sich B-E-R-T-H-U-L-D.
Okay, danke. Herr Berthold, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin jetzt 24 Jahre alt.
Okay, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
5. Mai 1999.
1999, ja? Okay. Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Berthold?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,85.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
So 68 Kilo ungefähr.
68 Kilo. Okay.
Vielen Dank für die Informationen.
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie, Herr Berthold?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Doch, ich fange vielleicht mal an, was ich glaube, was das Problem ist.
Und zwar, ich hatte vor ungefähr einer Woche eine Mandelentzündung gehabt.
Also Halsschmerzen, die Mandelungen auch angeschwollen.
Ist das ein bisschen besser geworden?
Da habe ich aber so einen Zahnschmerzen bekommen.
Am besten so einen Abszess im Zahn.
Und da war ich vor zwei Tagen beim Zahnarzt.
Und der hat dann gesagt, dass der Zahn faul ist.
Und dann musste gezogen werden.
Der hat den Zahn dann gezogen, dann gespült.
Und danach haben die Schmerzen auch ein bisschen nachgelasten.
Und jetzt habe ich seit gestern hohes Fieber bis 39,5.
Und auch Schüttelfrost.
Und ich fühle mich insgesamt sehr schwach.
Und deswegen komme ich jetzt zu Ihnen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Herr Berthold, haben Sie wegen Mandelentzündung
irgendwelche Medikamente angenommen?
Habe ich nicht.
Okay, vor der Zahn entfernen oder Abszess,
hatten Sie eine Antibiotik im Eingenommen?
Nein, verlobte habe ich nicht.
Ich habe nichts eingenommen.
Ich möchte so.
Und Sie haben gesagt, seit gestern haben Sie Fieber und Schüttelfrost.
Wo haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Mit einem Fieberthermometer.
Das habe ich mir von einem Freund aus gelegen.
Ich wohne im Mound oder Abszess.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Nachtschweiß haben Sie?
Ich habe keine Apetit.
Ich habe nichts essen seit zwei Tagen.
Ich habe auch Gelenkbeschwerden.
Ich habe auch ein bisschen Beschwerden im linken Oberbauch.
Das drückt so ein bisschen.
Meine Luft ist auch nicht so gut.
Ich habe viele Probleme.
Auf der Haut habe ich auch so auf den Unterarm.
Ich habe auch so ein bisschen Schüttelfrost.
Auf der Haut habe ich auch so auf den Unterarm und den Schenkel.
Ich habe auch so Punkte gesehen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das was bedeutet.
Rote Punkte haben Sie.
Unterarm und unter Schenkel.
Genau, ja.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie beim Gelenke?
Und welche Gelenke haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Schulte, Gelenke, Knie, Knöchel.
Das sind viele Gelenke, die mir wehtun.
Gibt es Schwellung auch an Gelenken?
Nur Schmerzen?
Manchmal kann man bei der Grippe das vorkommen.
So habe ich das ungefähr empfunden.
Grippe auch.
Wie bei einer Grippe?
Wie bei einer Grippe, wo ein Gelenkschmerzen haben kann.
So fühlt sich das an.
Haben Sie auch gelenkliche Schmerzen?
Ja, das ist so.
Ja, Schwäche habe ich.
Und dass diese gelenkliche Schmerzen, kann beides sagen.
Ja, okay.
Wie ist die Hautrötung?
Wie groß?
Die Hautrötung habe ich nicht.
Die Hautveränderung, die unter den Schenken.
Ah, diese Punkte, die sind klein, wie Stecknadelkopf.
So klein sind sie.
So, okay.
Zunach nicht weh.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Punkte?
Seit gestern.
Gelenkschmerzen auch seit gestern.
Okay.
Haben Sie Beinödem bemerkt?
Was sind Beine, die du haben, Doktor?
So dicke Bein.
Bein ist nicht dick, nein.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Leiden Sie unter Herzstrasen oder Herzstolpern?
Also Herzstrasen habe ich, ja.
Seit gestern oder früher haben Sie auch.
Seit gestern, hauptsächlich früher, habe ich auch immer wieder mal
ein bisschen Herzrasen gespürt.
Aber seit gestern ist das hauptsächlich so, dass ich das merke.
Ja, leiden Sie unter Atemnoten?
Ja, ich bin kurzartig jetzt, ja.
Diese Atemnoten, die haben ich,
die haben ich, die haben ich, die haben ich,
diese Atemnoten sind abhängig von Belastung
oder in Ruhe aufgetreten sein?
In Ruhe nicht, bei Belastung, wenn ich jetzt irgendwo aufstehe
und Treppen steige, dann habe ich gemerkt,
dass das nicht so einfach ist wie früher, wo ich kenne.
Ich verstehe.
So, Sie haben auch gesagt, Herr Berthold,
Sie haben sich im linken Oberbau geschmolzen.
Ja, so ein Druckgefühl, ja, habe ich auch gestern.
Strellen diese Schmerzen irgendwo hin aus
oder lokalisiert nur im linken Oberbau?
Ja, so, die sind im linken Oberbau, ja.
Okay, so, Herr Berthold,
hat sich Ihr Gewicht in Deinem Nesterland seit Märklich verändert?
Nein, ich bin immer so, die 68 Mal, paar Kilometer,
paar Kilowenige, aber ungefähr.
Ja, die sind seit der Woche.
Wie ist Ihr Schlaf?
Also, seit zwei Tagen kann ich nicht gut schlafen.
Auch deswegen Fieber konnte ich nicht gut schlafen.
Ja, ich verstehe, das ist normal.
Vor vorher habe ich jetzt keine großen Probleme mit dem Schlafen.
Okay, alles klar.
So, haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Haben Sie, ich meine, Durchfall oder Verstopfung?
Verstopfung, weiß ich nicht, ich habe jetzt wenig gegessen
in den letzten drei, vier Tagen und habe jetzt vor drei Tagen
letztlich Stuhlgang gehabt, also sonst habe ich jetzt keine Probleme.
Sie haben vor drei Tagen Stuhl abgesetzt, ja.
Hat sich Auffälligkeiten Ihren Stuhl?
Nein, normal.
Aber ich esse halt auch weniger jetzt seit zwei Tagen.
Ja, das ist normal.
So, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe nur gemerkt, dass seit gestern scheumt das viel, wenn ich Wasser lasse.
Scheumt mich, okay.
Also, Klosett?
Gibt es, ja, gab es Blut?
Nein.
Nur schaumt mich, ja.
Also, das ist mir aufgefallen, war früher nie so, dass es so aufgefallen hat.
Wie war die Farbe?
Normal, ist ein bisschen dunkel, weil ich wenig getrunken habe, glaube ich,
aber sonst normal.
Ja, ich verstehe so.
Bartolt, wie ist Ihr Hals jetzt?
Haben Sie noch Schluckbeschwerden?
Nein, das ist besser.
Besser.
Sie haben keine Schmerzen im Hals.
Im Hals habe ich keine Schmerzen, nur ein bisschen da, wo der Zahn gezogen ist,
aber auch nicht so viel.
Ich habe nicht ganz genau verstehen.
Ihren Zahnarzt hat Ihren Zahn entfernt, oder nur abzess?
Also er hat gesagt, der Zahn ist faul und da musste er ziehen,
weil die Entzündung da drin war, der gesagt hat,
da musste den Zahn ziehen, das dann abzess gewesen.
Okay, okay.
Alles klar, jetzt verstehe ich.
Als, ja, jetzt ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Vorerkrankung anstellen.
Herr Bartolt, Sie sind sehr jung, aber leiden Sie irgendwelche chronische Vorerkrankungen?
Ich meine, wie Bluthoffdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Ich habe bis letztes Jahr Heroin gedrückt.
Und seit ungefähr einem Jahr bin ich auf Methadone eingestellt.
Im Jahr war ich auch ein paar Mal rückfällig,
aber jetzt versuche ich, das Konsequenz mit Methadone zu machen.
Wie lange haben Sie Heroin?
Ich habe es seit drei, vier Jahren bestimmt.
Okay, haben Sie auch Spitze benutzen?
Wie meinen Sie?
Mit anderen Drogen oder Heroin?
Früher hatte ich andere Drogen, dann war ich lange Zeit nur auf Heroin.
Und jetzt, wie gesagt, seit ungefähr einem Jahr habe ich jetzt Methadone
und versuche nicht mehr zu spritzen.
Was für andere Drogen haben Sie angenommen aus Heroin?
Ich habe mit Cannabis angefangen, Schule noch,
und dann ist dann so langsam, habe ich andere Sachen noch probiert,
und dann letztlich war ich lange auf Heroin.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Okay, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf
irgendwelche Medikamente oder andere Substanzen?
Also ich habe jetzt nur das Methadone.
Und sonst habe ich halt so Schmerzmedikamente,
wenn ich das Problem habe, Überprophäen habe ich manchmal genommen.
Okay, Methadone, wie oft nehmen Sie pro Tag?
Einmal 60 Milligramm.
Einmal 60 Milligramm, okay.
So, diese Methadone von Ihrer Arztverschreibung, oder?
Ja, von der Drogenambulanz, ja.
Alles klar, Herbert, so, wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, ich war letztes Jahr im Krankenhaus,
da war ich noch auf Heroin,
und da hatte ich auch einen Abszess gehabt,
hier in der Schulter, war der Axel.
Rechts Schulter?
Ja, richtig Schulter, da ist das operiert worden,
also musste aufgemacht werden, dann war ich aber auch vier Wochen lang im Krankenhaus,
und dann habe ich dann noch Antibiotika auch bekommen,
und dann sagten wir, es wäre nicht in Ordnung und so weiter,
aber ich weiß nicht mehr genau.
Nach der Operation und Antibiotikum war alles gut?
Ja.
So in der Schulter?
Weil wir es dann besser geworden, ja.
Okay, ich frage mich.
Sind Sie allergisch auf irgendwelche Substanz oder Medikamente?
Nein, natürlich.
Haben Sie Unverträglichkeiten, Herbert, hold?
Nein, nicht.
So, rauchen Sie Zigarette?
Manchmal, also nicht regelmäßig,
rauch manchmal, dann rauch ich wieder nicht, also sehr unregelmäßig.
Duschnicklich, wie oft rauchen Sie?
Vielleicht in der Woche, ein, zwei Schatten Zigaretten,
vielleicht, manchmal auch gar nicht, an manchen Tagen gar nicht,
und dann wieder.
Ich sage, das weiß ich so, dass ich aufpassen muss,
dass ich weiß, ich kaufe, muss nicht sehr teuer mittlerweile,
deswegen versucht es wirklich wenig zu machen.
Ja, okay, verstehe.
Seit wann rauchen Sie, Herr Bertrand?
Ah, schon, da war ich 14, 15 Jahre alt in der Schule,
habe ich anders gesagt.
Ja, so trinken Sie Alkohol?
Selten.
Was für Alkohol trinken Sie?
Bier oder auch mal Schnaps aber.
Sehr unregelmäßig.
Okay.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Nein.
Ja, Herbert, sind Sie ledig oder?
Ja, ich gebe alle.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Was machen Sie als Berufli?
Ich bin arbeitslos.
Seit wann sind Sie arbeitslos?
Also jetzt, ich habe früher immer wieder mal hier und dort gearbeitet,
aber unregelmäßig, jetzt, so ungefähr,
im halben Jahr habe ich jetzt keine Arbeit.
Haben Sie bestimmte Berufe?
Nein, ich habe die Schule abgebrochen und habe hier und da mal gejobbt,
aber habe ich keine Ehre gemacht.
Okay, ich verstehe, alles klar.
Wie ist Ihr Impfstatus?
Mal sehen, ob Corona auch gegen Kinderkrankheiten ist.
Das weiß ich nicht, war noch da.
Vorher habe ich damals drei Impfungen gemacht, das weiß ich noch.
Okay.
Die anderen Kinderkrankheiten weiß ich nicht.
Ich verstehe.
Okay, waren Sie in Danez dann drei Monaten im Ausland?
Nein.
Okay, jetzt, ich möchte etwas fragen zu Ihrer Familiengeschichte.
Gibt es wichtige Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Also, meinen Vater habe ich nie kennengelernt,
aber der Mutter habe ich jetzt auch keinen Kontakt mehr,
aber ich weiß nicht, wer hatte,
ich glaube, ich hatte Zuckerhazie, aber ich bin nicht sicher, ob das...
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ja, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe eine.
Ja, Herr Bert, ich möchte jetzt ein kleines Zusammenfassung machen.
Dann, wenn ich etwas nicht vergesse oder falsch verstehe,
korrigieren Sie mich bitte.
Einfach schon von oben.
Für einen, der einen ist, haben Sie Mandelentsündung,
dagegen haben Sie keine Medikamente.
Für zwei Tage haben Sie Zahnschmerzen wegen Absäß,
so, die Zahn wurde entfernt.
Seit gestern, Sie haben 39,5 Grad Fieber und Schüttelfrost.
Zusätzlich Gelenkschmerzen, Hautpunkte,
Unterarm- und Unter-Schenkel.
Links, Oberbauchschmerzen, Geliedeschmerzen,
Herzstraßen und beim Belastung auch Atemnot.
Ja.
Ja, so, haben Sie solche Besperrten früher gehabt
oder das ist erst malig?
Also damals, als ich diese Abszesse hatte,
hatte ich auch so Besperren gehabt.
Und Sie waren nicht beim anderen als deswegen, ja?
Ich meine, diese seit gestern.
Nein, die ist direkt zurückgekommen.
Okay.
Und Ihre Appetit ist nicht so gut, auch schlafen nicht so gut
wegen der aktuelle Besperrten.
Sie haben auch schleumige Wasserlassen.
Ja, das ist jetzt ein, ja, also es hat geschäumt beim Wasserlassen.
Das weiß ich vielleicht, hat es auch nichts zu bedeuten,
ich weiß nicht.
Wir waren dann alles überprüfen, keine Sorge.
Ja, so, möchten Sie noch etwas hinzukrücken
oder fragen Sie an mich?
Ja, ich hatte gesagt, habe ich Ihnen gesagt,
letztes Jahr war ich im KGNAUS vier Wochen lang,
habe ich gesagt, gell, wegen...
Ja, ich habe alles...
...Zenten, Zutrika, und dann war das Herz wohl auch ein Problem,
aber noch nichts genaues weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Also wegen dieser Herz der Problemen
waren Sie nicht beim Kardiologien?
Nein, die haben ich vier Wochen lang mit an die Würtiker waren
und dann habe ich noch ein paar Wochen lang zu Hause
an die Würtiker genommen und dann war ich nicht mehr beim Arzt gewesen.
Okay.
Dann habe ich den Theroid auch gehört danach.
Ah, okay.
Aber haben Sie keine Operationen außer Absäß?
Nein.
Okay, ich verstehe.
So, Herr Bertolt, jetzt werde ich Ihnen körperlich untersuchen,
dann Blut abnehmen
und dann werde ich auch Herzurtraschall
und Bauchurtraschall durchführen.
Ja, Sie können...
...Ja, Behandlungsraum gehen, ich komme gleich.
Und ich muss dann im Krankenhaus bleiben
oder ich würde gerne im Krankenhaus bleiben, wenn es geht?
Ja, je nach alle Ergebnisse können wir nochmal wieder mit Ihnen sprechen.
Ja, also ich bleibe gerne im Krankenhaus, wenn es nur notwendig ist,
mache ich gerne.
Okay, ja, ich werde meinem Oberarzt bescheid geben.
Okay, danke schön.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Also war alles gut gefragt, ne?
Ja, aber ein paar Fragen müssen wir stellen.
Okay, bitte, dann fangen Sie an.
Okay, Sie haben gesagt, linke Oberbauküche, Mersen.
Ja, ich werde.
Irgendwärsche, Aksel, oder Halse, Lymphadenopathy,
oder was bedeutet, Deutsch, Ich weiß nicht.
Lymphadenopathy, bemerkst du?
Lymphotenschwellung.
Ja, Lymphotenschwellung.
Hat er nicht gemerkt, ne?
Okay.
Haben Sie seit vier, fünf Jahren keinen Partner?
Keine Partner.
Okay.
Haben Sie ein Engelgefühl oder Druckgefühl in Diyabruss?
Nein, da nicht, nein.
Dann habe ich eine Frage.
Bitte, ja.
Wie ist der Allgemeinstudiant der Patient?
Er ist sehr schwach.
Er wird sehr schwach abgeschlagen, keiner geht.
Ja, und vorher haben Sie eine Infektionneigung
oder Munchwäsche?
Munchwäsche hat er sonst nichts gesagt.
Vor einer Woche ging es ihm gut,
hat auch keine Probleme vorher gehabt.
Er hat jetzt Test gemacht, bevor er mit Methadone angefangen hat
oder negativ bei V.
Das ist auch richtig.
Haben Sie Sehstörung?
Sehstörung gestern kurz mal, ja.
Jetzt wieder besser.
Bekommen Sie Atemnot, wenn Sie verlach liegen?
Nein.
Sind die Lesionen, die am Unteramtschecken bestehen,
schmerzhaft oder nicht?
Er hat gesagt, nicht schmerzhaft, nicht juckend.
Sind Sie seit gestern oder in nächster Zeit
unmächtig geworden?
Nein.
Danke schön.
Sie erwähnen, bei Ihnen eine punktförmige Hautveränderung zu haben.
Habt ihr das verstanden?
Punktförmige Hautveränderung zu haben.
Diese Veränderungen, wann haben Sie bemerkt?
Gestern.
Gestern?
Neu.
Pathechen.
Ja, die Patienten wissen nicht, was Pathechen sind,
aber es sind Pathechen.
Können wir als Arztgespräch anfangen?
Wenn keine weiteren Fragen sind, können wir Arztgespräch anfangen.
Okay, okay.
Bitte schön, Abla.
Bitte schön.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten gerade aufgenommen,
den ich Ihnen gerne vorstellen möchte.
Das ist kurz.
Okay, danke.
Es geht um Thomas Berthold.
Er ist 24 Jahre alt, am 5. Mai 1990 geboren.
Er ist 1,85 m groß, 860 kg schwer.
Herr Thomas Berthold, hat Sie heute bei uns wegen,
wegen seit gestern plötzlich aufgetretener Fieber
und Schütterfrost vorgestellt.
Außerdem habe er erörter der Patienten,
dass vor einer Woche Tonsilitis mit Fieber habe.
Aber dagegen habe er keine Medikamente.
Tonsilitis mit Fieber oder ohne Fieber?
Ohne Fieber.
Vor zwei Tagen habe er Zahnschmerzen.
Besucht er Zahnarzt,
eine Zahnabsehs- und Pfeule festgestellt wurde.
Und ihren Zahn wurde entfernt.
Vor der Eingriff hat er keine Antibiotik.
Seit gestern habe er 39,5 Grad Fieber,
das im Mund gemessen sei.
Zusätzlich erwähnte er, dass Artralgie im Schulter,
Alborgen und Klinikelen,
Glyde Schmerzen auf,
ja, noch, RHB auf,
im Linken Epigastrium, Schmerz HB,
Linken Unterbau oder Epigastrium?
Oberbau.
Linken Unterbau, Oberbau.
Nicht Epigastrium und Oberbau.
Ja, Epigastrium, linker Oberbau.
Des Weiteren sind den Patienten,
die folgenden Beglattsymptome aufgefallen.
Fatiguille, Tachycardiopetetchen,
ja, am Unterarm und unter Schenkel,
Belastungsdispine, ja, und schleumige Wasalasen.
Die vegetative Anamnese sei unauffällig,
bis auf seit zwei Tagen beschwerde Bedingte in Appetenz und Schlafstörungen.
Er habe letzte Stuhlgang vor drei Tagen gehabt.
Ja, es sind keine relevanten Vererkrankungen bekannt.
Als in Bezug auf Medikamente nehme er Methadone 60 mg,
einmal pro Tag wegen der Heroin Abusus,
bei Bedarf nehme er Ibuprofen ein.
Vor einem Jahr wurde er stationär behandelt
wegen rechter Schulter Absäß.
Er wurde deswegen operiert und vier Wochen
im Krankenhaus geblieben.
Es sind keine Allergen und Unverträglichkeiten bekannt.
Er hat eine oder zwei Schachtel pro Woche oder pro Monat geraucht.
Seit fünf Jahren, seit der Unregelmäßigkeit des Alkohol,
hat er drei bis vier Jahre aufgeführt.
Er hat eine oder zwei Schachtel pro Woche oder pro Monat geraucht.
Er hat seit drei bis vier Jahren unterschiedliche Drogen genannt.
Er hat Heroin konsumiert.
Aber seit einem Jahr hat er Entzugtherapie mit Methadone angefangen.
Er ist ledig und wohne allein.
Er ist ein halb Jahr arbeitslos.
Sein Status gegen Corona-Forschstände,
gegen Kinderkrankheit, unbekannt.
Die Reise an Amnese war unauffällig.
Familien an Amnese waren unauffällig,
weil er keine Engekontakte hatte.
Alle Anamnese sind auf eine Infektiv- und Kardit wegen Tonsilitis und Sanopérationen.
Es gibt auch eine große Risikofaktor, Drogenabusus.
Vor einem Jahr?
Nein, aber vielleicht nicht so stark.
Aber das ist ja einem Jahr.
Er hat keine Heroin mehr.
Er hat Akut auftreten, Fieber sehr hoch.
Ich bin Kardiologe.
Hat mit Heroin nichts zu tun?
Alles was zu tun mit Heroin, ist Akute endokalitis?
Nein, Kokain.
Was ist das mit Kokain?
Eigentlich bin ich nicht sehr auf das etwas machen.
Aber er hat auch Stritte benutzen.
Bei wem ist das Risiko an der Infektiv- endokalitis erhöht?
Unabhängiges von Drogenpatienten.
Bei welchen Patienten ist das Risiko, wenn man einen Infektiv- endokalitis bekommt?
Normalerweise vielleicht Diabetes, Melitus, Kronische, Leberkrankheit.
Bei welchen Patienten ist das Risiko erhöht, dass sie einen endokalitis entwickeln?
Bei welchen Patienten ist das Risiko erhöht?
Vielleicht ist es mit Fälen, Kardiak-Struktur, z.B. ACD oder WCD.
Was ist ACD?
ACD.
Es geht in die richtige Richtung.
Und Herzklappen- Schwere?
Bei Patienten mit Herzklappen- schädigungen.
RHB, Tachikard, seit gestern aber früher RHB, auch manchmal Tachikard.
Was ist auch eine Anamnese, die wichtigste, die bei diesen Patienten auf Herzklappen- Störungen oder Krankheit schließen könnten?
Was hat er erzählt?
Bei Belastung war RHB erdyspine.
Was früher war bei ihm?
Früher habe er im Krankenhaus.
Damals war er Antibiotikum geschrieben.
Aber er hat sich nicht regernen.
Er hat aber vier Wochen im Krankenhaus Antibiotikum bekommen.
Er hat damals Heroin gespritzt.
Er hat damals eine Bakterie entwickelt.
Er hatte eine Endokartitis, die mit vier Wochen Antibiotikum war.
Er hatte eine Herzklappen-Vorschädigung.
Er hat eine Herzklappen-Schädigung.
Er hat eine Endokartitis, die mit dem Boden einer geschädigten Herzklappe entwickelt.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Nein, ich habe Fieber.
Ich habe ein schlechtes Zustand.
Ich möchte die Patientin stationär aufnehmen.
Welche Diagnostik machen Sie, damit Sie den Verdacht auf Endokartitis bestätigen können?
Zuerst werde ich beim Labor BSG, TRP, Blutbild und Lebe unter den Nierenwerten bestimmen.
Ich werde die Patientin mit einer Eko-Kardiografie machen.
Ich würde eine Antibiotik-Therapie machen.
Nach dem Nachweis von Erreger und Resistenz-Ergebnissen könnte ich umstellen.
Die Blutkultur nehmen Sie vor der Antibiotik-Gabe ab.
Die Fernsehldiagnostik?
Die Sceptische Artritis könnte sein.
Die Antibiotik-Therapie kann schnell einleiten.
Ist es eine leichte Erkrankung?
Die Sceptische Artritis kann sich an der Schädigung an der Erkrankung an der Erkrankung beenden.
Frau Doktor, ist das gefährlich, was ich habe?
Ich werde sagen, Sie haben wegen der Infektions-Herzschädigung.
Was kann passieren bei den Patienten mit der Erkrankung?
Die Erkrankung ist sehr ernst.
Was ist das für eine Diagnostik?
Ich denke, dass die Patientin die Infektions-Hermitung hat.
Wenn Sie das in der Prüfung sagen, dann sind Sie durchgefallen.
Ich habe noch andere Fragen.
Auch wenn die Kardiologen eine andere Meinung sind.